all right today we we have really an
extraordinary opportunity to welcome
world chrétien holidays professor Tom
Schroeder is here with us he is the
professor you can go through the sea
bean Panama but I'll I'll shorten up
before you more than 20 books these
scholar in the field when Kenda Cressy
Dean longer critiques of you please look
like one year of Mickey Mouse hat that
just sits out there like it has no
connection but this is exactly what our
guests and they're focusing on how to
preach and conduct worship so the entire
body of Christ can be fed and so then in
our worship been moved and inspired and
fed by the same sermon that we're
pitching to the rafters for all ages of
our congregation nobody appreciates
concerned about this
there is something wrong with this
system ah can you all hear me good I'm
going to project my voice then and hope
I last well I think I will I want to
begin by thanking skip for his
invitation and reading to you what he
wrote me quote I know you have a deep
interest in helping preachers reach
folks of all ages I wonder if you would
be willing to address the challenge of
crafting messages so that they will
reach youth and children so that is
precisely what I'm going to talk about
today but the way that I'm going to
address this will not only address youth
and children it will also help engage
adults in profounder ways we're going to
look at two theories that help us and
I'll actually illustrate them with brief
sermons so you can experience them
you'll get to analyze them and
understand them I begin with two stories
about children from church life the
first is about a little girl oh four
four-and-a-half years old she and her
mother were in the car riding to an
important medical appointment and as
they approached the church the little
girl said mommy we've got to stop and
feed the baby Jesus and her mother
looked at her and said what do you mean
Jesus he was born in our church last
week well they did the Christmas pageant
so the mother said to her said to the
little girl no honey that was that was
just a pageant no I saw her I saw him he
was born in our church
the child began to become profoundly
upset she said I'm sure he's hungry
so the mother finally said to her you
know the Shepherd's will feed him and
she said oh that's okay we can go on
Story number two these are both true
stories this one comes from a church I
was attending the tradition of this
church on passion Sunday Palm Sunday was
to enact the passion story of Christ and
they always hired a professional actor
to play Christ they didn't want it hand
up they wanted it to be really well done
and as the passion story continues
there's a point where when the whole
congregation says crucify him crucify
him everybody stands up so behind me
just over my right shoulder there was a
mother with a little girl who I would
guess is about 3 to 4 and the way they
would crucify Jesus is we had a big Rood
screen this was in the Cathedral in
Denver and so Christ is like this on the
root screen and this was a really fine
actor and he hung his head and the
little girl said there was complete
silence and it echoed through the whole
Cathedral mommy they killed Jesus didn't
they there was there wasn't a single
person who didn't hear it well of course
the mother you know she's a little bit
embarrassed well honey it's just apply
it's just to play well in the way they
did the passion story they took Jesus
off the the Rood screen the cross and
the clergy of that church would carry
the body of Jesus down the aisle through
the congregation so as the body is
carried by the little girl she says
again in complete silence in the in the
cathedral know mommy he's really dead
and they carried him on out now I tell
these two stories because some
times we hear such stories and we think
our children cute no they're not cute
they're profound and wise and they know
things that we have forgotten and that
we need to know who will feed the baby
Jesus it's not enough to have a pageant
you've got to ask where is Christ hung
Goering and who will feed him and I'll
tell you I went to the coffee hour that
Sunday that passion Sunday no mommy he's
really dead
you know how usually you just have nice
chitchat at the coffee hour I talked for
over an hour with several people about
the meaning of the death of Jesus and it
was all because that child had said no
he's really dead and had compelled us
adults to see what had become smooth
down this is why we don't want the
children isolated like a Mouseketeer ear
because we need their wisdom in church
we need to hear them say who will feed
the baby Jesus no mommy he's really dead
now in both of these stories I think we
see illustrated Jesus principle truly I
tell you unless you change and become
like children you will never enter the
reign of God now children's primary ways
of knowing their basic ways of seeing
and processing the world are very
different from our highly developed and
highly reasoned adult ways of doing this
and to help us catch a flavor of this
I'm first going to share a little bit of
developmental theory and then I'm going
to I'll illustrate it from a book and
then I'll actually do a sermon using the
theory so you can see it all at once now
everybody should have received a packet
there is the chart I want you to turn to
says subject areas of thought
and at the top you'll see there's
magical and there is literal these are
the primary modes of cognition of the
young child and the young child who has
language like these two little girls
three and a half to four
they tend to be either magical or
depending on because development isn't
always sequential and we can't precisely
say or a literal the two can sometimes
flow together let's look at the world
the magical mixes fact and fancy no
mommy I saw Jesus born in the church
there it is she saw it it's concrete
it's literal the logic notice magical
appearance it's literally true the way
the mother come the little girl down was
not to reason as an adult it was a play
it was to enter the child's world and
reason as a child the shepherds will
feed him so that was actually a
brilliant move on that mother's part
preachers of every stripe need to make
that move more often to move into that
way of thinking notice if you move into
that way of thinking you all as adults
with adult reasoning you could follow
the story but you can take it at both
levels you can take it at the level at
which the child took it but you can
still stay at your adult level so this
is why you don't have to have the
Mouseketeer ear this is why the children
belong in worship there are ways of
speaking that will speak across all the
different levels the story there's
usually a striking feature for a child
no mommy he's really dead
that's the striking feature you can see
it right there the narrative is
one-dimensional literal the little girl
just insisted on the deadness now I'm
going to stop because I want to do a
little more before I complete the chart
and to do this I'm going to turn to a
book that I did with a wonderful
colleague out in Denver named Edie
Everdene Edie got his PhD in New
Testament from Harvard he started
teaching in seminaries and he realized
as he taught that the lecturing only got
through to certain students people who
like lectures but there are many other
people who had different ways of
learning and you couldn't really reach
him with lectures they weren't dumb they
just had different ways of processing
the world the result of this is that
Edie got profoundly interested in
educational theory and he's the one
who's introduced me to these theories
one of the theories is this
developmental theory the way young
people develop and have different modes
of cognition and he and a number of
scholars on a matter of fact I think
Lucinda were you involved in this study
yes Lucinda was involved in this study
and these were longitudinal studies that
is they would ask a child when he was in
the literal magical some questions about
interpreting the Bible then they'd wait
a few years and asked the same child
again and you could actually watch the
development of the child and some of
this is recorded it's very lively in
here I'm just going to read a little bit
but I want to read this bit of biblical
interpretation because it does one or
two things for you one it shows you why
it would pay you in creating your
sermons to ask children what they think
about the passage and get some input
from children that's another way to do
the kinds of things that I'm doing but
also it gives you an idea of how
concrete their world really is okay it
opens with a brief reading from
Scripture when asked if it was lawful to
cure on the Sabbath jesus replied
suppose one of you has only one sheep
and it falls into a pit on the Sabbath
will you not lay hold of it and lift it
out how much more valuable is a human
being than a sheep that's Matthew 12 10
to 11 the children were asked two
questions
should Jesus have broken the law which
is more important or more value a sheep
or a man some of the children used
magical ways of knowing Jesus should
have broken the law quote cause Jesus is
the boss who's you're gonna see when we
go back to charge who's big who's got
the authority okay
the Pharisees were quote bad
they're gonna kill Jesus very very clear
demarcations between good and bad then
here's an answer to which is worth more
Ashi p-- or a human being a sheep is
worth more because it can make clothes
if a man could make clothes the man in
the sheep would both be worth more than
a horse because a horse can't make
clothes it would depend on whether the
sheep was bigger or older than the man
now I'm telling you folks Jay you bring
that into a sermon and you're gonna have
the whole congregation with you okay and
then talk about how value decisions are
made okay now here here are some
examples of literal ways of knowing
Jesus should have broken the law because
quote I think it's a good thing to do at
least one or two good deeds on Sunday
Jesus is different he was kind of a good
guy and the Pharisees don't understand
him so well in this case it's right to
heal okay there's a there's a kid at a
literal level figuring it out okay also
the Pharisees were not justified in
being upset because quote they wanted to
be the Big Cheese see the people obeyed
the law they wanted to be the Big Cheese
this distinction between little and big
good and bad is very very clear at this
level and finally this one demands more
valuable the man it's more valuable
because the Sheep can turn into lamb
chops in them days the only things they
use the Sheep for was to eat and
sprinkle the blood over the fence posts
around the door
well let's see I think they could
probably do some things that a person
can I think the sheep's is important as
a man yeah okay no I
these things they make me laugh too but
they also give us an entrance into a way
of looking at reality and they show us
the human mind at a very early age
trying to put the world together and
what in the world is good preaching
about but putting the world together for
people now I want you to be able to see
the theory in action I've already named
one way you could do this in the
preparation of your regular sermon not
the children's sermon you can interview
children about how they see these
passages get the wisdom of children and
I actually I had begun to do that even
when I was a pastor sometimes and often
got some of my finest sermons from them
now the other thing that you can do is
you can preach a sermon from the
perspective of the literal the magical
literal perspective staying in it almost
all the way and I'm going to read a
passage of Scripture to you and I'm then
going to preach such a sermon to you as
you listen carefully you'll see at the
very beginning after a kind of dramatic
start there is a very brief interlude
that goes to adult reasoning for only a
few seconds the reason I put that in is
I first preached this sermon in
Chautauqua a highly super intellectual
head in the clouds type place and I
thought people won't listen to me unless
I can justify it but here is the text a
very famous text John six after this
Jesus went to the other side of the Sea
of Galilee also called the sea of
Tiberias a large crowd kept following
him because they saw the signs that he
was doing for the sick Jesus went up the
mountain and sat down there with his
disciples now the Passover the festival
of the Jews was near when he looked up
and saw a large crowd coming toward and
Jesus said to Phil
where are we to buy bread for these
people to eat he said this to test him
for he himself knew what he was going to
do Philip answered him six months wages
would not buy enough bread for each of
them to get a little one of his
disciples Andrew simon Peters brother
said to him there's a boy here who has
five barley loaves and two fish but what
are they among so many people
jesus said make the people sit down now
there was a great deal of grass in the
place so they sat down about five
thousand and all then Jesus took the
loaves and when he had given thanks he
distributed them to those who were
seated so all the fish as much as they
wanted when they were satisfied he told
his disciples gather up the fragments
left over so that nothing may be lost so
they gathered them up and from the
fragments of the five barley loaves left
by those who had been eaten they filled
twelve baskets when the people saw the
sign that he had done they began to say
this is indeed the prophet who is to
come into the world
I say I say you did not eat your lunch I
made for you yes I did mom honest I hate
the whole thing now the little boy isn't
actually given a name in the Bible but
I'm going to call him Isiah because
often the way we dispense with children
we devalue them as we call him the kid
the little boy the little girl so I'm
going to call him Isiah and I'm going to
call him Isiah because Isiah was Jesus
favorite prophet he quilts him more than
anybody else and furthermore Isaiah is
the one who said a little child will
lead them a verse which gets echoed in
Jesus own teaching about unless you
become like a child you cannot enter the
reign of God this is not a children's
sermon it is a sermon for children and
youth and adults but told primarily from
a child's perspective Isaiah Isaiah you
did not eat your lunch that I packed for
you yes I did mom honest I ate the whole
thing
I say you come here now I packed for you
two fish and five barley loaves now let
me count what's in here one two three
four five six seven seven barley laws I
say it did you bring home somebody
else's lunch
no I mom look at the handle you see
where it's broken you don't know yeah
you told me you ate your whole lunch
yeah mom I say it tell me exactly what
happened well mom I gave my lunch away
then I ate my lunch and then I had more
than before I ate it Isaiah that's not
possible that's not possible
mom all I know is what happened well
tell me what happened well you said I
could go here this teacher who I like to
listen to tells these great stories so
you packed me the lunch and I walked all
the way around it was a pretty long walk
up to this kind of big open field next
to the lake and I I walked right up to
this teacher he he's very nice to
children the adults often say hey get
out of here kid but he says come right
on up here even knows my name by now he
says I said come on up here and sit
except right here so I did so he starts
telling stories so what kind of stories
Isaiah oh they're really interesting
stories they're about the lost Cline's
and sheep oh and I have a favorite
there's this younger brother who asked
for all the allowance ever owed him in
life and his parents give it to him I
say uh what are these stories about
what's the point of them I don't know
what the point is mom I just know
they're really good stories and I I
think on them
well what happened then I say well
Isaiah says you could look around and
you could see everybody's getting hungry
you know how people look when they're
huh hungry well how many people are
there Isaiah gazillions there gazillions
of them um I tell you there aren't
gazillions in the world well all I know
is up and down every single Hill people
were seated everywhere as far as you
could see there were people okay what
happens next
well first he asks how they're gonna
feed them and then his friends says
would have to work for half a year we
wouldn't have enough money to feed as
many people so another one of his
friends comes over and he looks in my
picnic basket
hmm this kid here he's got two fish and
five barley laws well what did you do I
say well I hugged that basket I wasn't
going to give my basket up just cuz a
packer
crazy adults
brought lunch but then he looked at me
the teacher looked at me I know we
wouldn't force me to say it but he said
Isaiah so I gave him my lunch Isaiah I
packed that lunch for you why did you
give it away well mom I it was the tone
of his voice it was the stories he tells
and when I looked at him I thought of
you
what happened next Isaiah well he puts
his hands over it and he says blessed be
the god maker of heaven and earth and
then he starts going around with his
basket he comes to me and I took out my
two fish and my five loaves and he and
his friends they start going all around
the hill and they say to everybody take
what you need take what you need take
what you need
take what you need take what you need
take what you need take what you need
take what you need take what you need
take what you need take what you need
take what you need and after a while the
people start coming back and they empty
out the baskets in there there was
enough to fill 12 more baskets and he
had me come up he says Isaiah this is
your basket I said yeah and he counted
out one two three four five you had five
years six seven well by then mom I was
pretty tired so I thought I oughta come
home so I I I started home but you know
what all the way home I was thinking to
myself Isaiah what were you thinking I
was thinking you can feed a whole lot
more people than you think you can all
you have to do is take what you have and
have Jesus bless
and then there's enough for everybody
here mom take what you need okay now I
want you to take the chart and just go
down through the chart it where I
haven't necessarily used everything but
just make a few remarks to yourself for
notes and then I'm going to let each of
you talk with one another just for a few
minutes about how we use this
I don't like just to yell at people to
come back it's nice to hear you see now
we're going I know we are moving quickly
but I've deliberately given you the
handouts and an outline so you're going
to be able to go away we will be out of
here by 2:00 I know that that's the
contract but I want to keep moving along
because I want you to have a substantial
amount of material from the gathering
and we're going to move now from simply
a theory about developmental on knowing
into another theory and to make this
shift I'm just going to tell you a very
brief story out of my own childhood and
then that will lead into the next theory
which is even more elaborate and we'll
take a little more time to layout and
then I will do another sermon and let
you use the theory again to analyze what
is happening when I was a little boy I
had a wonderful wonderful father and I I
just adored him and I can remember every
now and then I would dress up in his
clothes of course absolutely nothing fit
me I had to roll up the trousers I had
to roll up my jacket sleeves I I would
put his necktie on which I didn't really
know how to tie but I would put it on
and it would trail down in front of me
like a carpet in front and I used to put
on men back in those days I was born in
45 min wore Stetsons they were kind of a
looks like a cowboy hat so to speak only
a little more formal I can remember I
would put it on and I had to wear it
cockeyed so I could see myself in the
mirror well you know I was not dressing
enclosed that I fit I was dressing for
what I hope to grow up to be Colossians
says clothed yourselves in compassion
kindness patience humility above all
clothes yourselves in love let the Peace
of Christ dwell in your heart it
wouldn't surprise me if what Colossians
is describing is basically true for all
of us he's describing not the clothes
that we fit into but the ones we hope to
grow up into that system that that
process of maturation whereby we finally
begin to fill out what it is to love and
to have compassion and to have humility
one of the major aspects of growing up
is that becoming mature I once went to a
party and I asked a little boy I said
what do you want to be when you grow up
I can remember when I was a kid I
thought there was the dumbest question
in the world but of course as an adult I
asked it of many children and this
little kid was not being smartass with
me he said when I grow up I want to
become an adult and I thought what a
wonderful goal and how many of us have
failed to reach it I want to be an adult
so one of the major aspects of growing
into the full stature of Christ involves
growing from childhood into youth and
from youth into adulthood another reason
why I don't like the Mickey Mouse ear
approached youth ministry because we
need all of us there in order to help
all of us do the growing including us
adults the process of maturing involves
engaging all the gifts of knowing and
learning that God has given us that is
part of maturation
is claiming all that God has given us to
be the way I sometimes put this in just
a very brief phrase is all of us for all
of God now Christ himself acknowledges
this principle when he says the first
commandment is here o Israel the Lord
our God is one and you shall love the
Lord your God with all your heart and
all your
and all your soul and all your strength
I love in mark is the one that has the
word strength its use in Greek it means
literally muscular bodily strength and
so this involves the person who has
grown up in terms of their body from
childhood the second is this you shall
love your neighbor as yourself now I
want you to notice how the first and
greatest commandment invokes every
Faculty of knowing and being that God
has given us if we stress a single
Faculty of knowing and being at the
expense of the other we end up
distorting our relationship to God if we
love God with all our heart but not with
all our mind then feeling runs untested
and unchecked by reason site and we will
not grow up into the full stature of
Christ if we love God with all our mind
but not with all our heart then our
thought becomes entirely calculating
lacking tenderness and grace and we will
not grow up into the full stature of
Christ or if we love God with all our
soul but not with all our strength and
the word strength here means physical
bodily strength then we fail to embody
our faith in acts of compassion and we
will not grow up into the full stature
of Christ if we love God with all our
strength but not with all our soul then
our lives become spiritually vacuous and
we will not grow up into the full
stature of Christ by way of contrast
when we give all of us to all of God
then faith becomes a process of allowing
our varied ways of knowing to correct
and balance each other so that we do
grow up into the full stature of Christ
I think this would be a great goal if
you're trying to formulate a goal for
your ministry with children and youth
what about growing up into the full
stature of Christ you couldn't do much
better for a goal we're now going to
consider a theory of human knowing that
will help us as preachers engage all our
heart and soul and mind and strength and
the act of creating and delivering
sermons so that the sermons engage the
hearts and minds and souls and strength
of young people and adults and
children this theory has down-to-earth
practical applications for the creation
and delivery of sermons it suggests ways
of engaging all the powers God has given
you to help your youthful listeners come
to the measure of the full stature of
Christ
that's Ephesians 4:13 now I want you to
get to another chart this time it says
the multiple intelligences chart you're
gonna have to one has definitions in it
the other is empty save the empty one
aside because we're gonna do an exercise
with that later on once again I'm highly
indebted to my colleague at everting in
Denver who taught me about this theory I
used to do a lot of preaching in the
Episcopal Cathedral in Denver I'm an
Episcopal priest and a Presbyterian
minister but for many years I did a lot
of preaching in the cathedral and when
word got out that I was preaching people
would bring their families in Mass and
it was a kind of an interesting
phenomenon and it said to me do you know
why the families come out and I said no
he says because you use every
intelligence that you have when you
preach and the result is its engaging
and children are able to remember things
oh I forgot to tell you one story about
the first sermon I did on the feeding of
the 5,000 I did it first and should talk
well I then because somebody had been
there from Florida they wanted me to
come down to their church and do it and
I did it and they had loads of children
and I I said that day I don't want a
children's sermon this will be the adult
sermon so that afternoon or evening I
was to do a lecture just for adults very
adult thing but a mother came up to me
before the lecture she said I and my
child were in church this morning I've
got to tell you the following thing she
said we stopped by the grocery store to
pick up some milk on the way home from
service and I saw a woman in the aisle
and I said you should have heard this
sermon we heard in church and she says I
started to tell it and my six-year-old
said no mommy let me tell it and he told
it from beginning to end accurately see
because it was a child it was at that
level it's interesting though the woman
had in
tended to tell it to her friend so you
notice see it's both at the adult and
the child's level now these the the next
thing I want to look at is multiple
intelligences because Edie was the one
who said to me you use multiple
intelligences I had no idea that that
was what I was doing but he said you and
I should teach a course on this and sure
enough we actually put a course together
and we taught it as a Doctor of Ministry
course tour ministers who were there all
of them active creatures we got several
letters from congregation members thank
you our ministers no longer boring and
we can follow him
I mean I'm not making that up that
actually happened so this stuff works I
have empirical data it works so you just
try it okay now the theory comes from a
man named Howard Gardner a very
distinguished professor up at Harvard
who is a really an epistemology somebody
who's studied human cognition and theory
is basically that we there are eight
primary intelligences that human beings
have he thinks there may be more than
eight but he has very strict scientific
criteria for naming and intelligence it
has to fit into a certain evolutionary
pattern it has to be located in a
particular part of the brain so for
example if that part of the brain is
damaged people actually lose that
intelligence they're not able to use it
anymore it has to be amenable to being
cultivated that is in other words there
are things you can do you can have some
kind of culture which stimulates this
intelligence a great deal and his
favorite example of this is the suzuki
violin method you all know what I mean
about we're very little children learned
play the violin before Suzuki method
violin which is one of the most
difficult instruments in the world to
play they thought you can't start it
till much later they discovered that's
not true if you put children together in
a culture of learning how to play the
violin they can learn at an unbelievably
early age very quickly so where he comes
out on the famous nature-nurture thing
is yes it is by nature that you may have
this intelligence but you can nurture it
we're going to assume
handicapping conditions in somebody and
we're going to look at all eight before
I begin people often ask me what about
the emotional intelligence his answer to
that is every one of these has an
emotional side and in other words any of
these intelligences can take you to an
emotional state so he doesn't list
emotion as an individual intelligence I
want to start in the lower right hand
corner because the upper left-hand
corner is the one that most preachers
have naturally developed the most the
naturalist or nature smart intelligence
this is the recognition in
classification of numerous species of
one's environment in flora and fauna so
this is an intelligence which is
extremely able to relate to all kinds of
natural phenomena the intra personal
this is the capacity to understand
oneself have an effective working model
of one's self regulate one's life
effectively it's one of the major
intelligences that anybody in ministry
needs because we've got to know what's
the appropriate use of ourselves what's
the inappropriate use water boundaries
all those kinds of issues
then the interpersonal one understand
the intentions motivations desires of
other people work effectively with
others again something that is just
called on perpetually for people who are
in ministry and particularly I can
remember in youth ministry in dealing
with junior High's especially sometimes
my interpersonal smarts were pushed to
the height then the spatial is a picture
smart the potential to recognize the
manipulate patterns of wide space pilots
do this or patterns of more confined
space for example I tried to use you may
have noticed I used space and take what
you need take what you need take what
you need take what you need okay so I'm
trying to indicate the big space of the
hills okay the body can aesthetic body
smart the using of one's whole body or
using parts of the body to solve
problems or fashion products so a place
where I use the body smart was remember
the little boy grabs the basket okay
that's body smart
musical music smart skill and
performance composition appreciation for
musical patterns now I want to be honest
Gardner himself doesn't do this but I
have extended the musical intelligence
to the use of the voice while one is
speaking I say I say it is actually a
musical phrase it hasn't interval then
logical-mathematical this is the logical
smart capacity to analyze problems
logically carry out mathematical
operations investigate issues
scientifically that was present in the
mother you notice okay how could it be I
gave you the five loaves to fish that
math doesn't add up
and then the linguistic our word smart
is sensitivity to spoken and written
language ability to learn languages
capacity to use language to accomplish
certain goals I smart that most
preachers develop to an extremely high
degree now the thing that I love about
this chart is there are so many
different ways to use it in the creation
of a sermon the next time you are
reading a passage from the Bible look
for how many smarts are involved in it
you'll be amazed it may give you a whole
new you it what it does is it takes you
away from that heady verbosity which is
the bane of preaching and that will just
kill your sermons with youth and
children okay
so just using these intelligences as you
read the scriptures can help you when
you have finished your sermon ask how
many of these intelligences have I
involved now I find I don't engage I
think everyone in every sermon although
I'm about to preach a sermon which
usually people tell me oh yeah I was
able to get all eight out of it but it
can help you expand the repertoire of
what you are doing it can help you find
the language the use of your body and
your voice that you need to engage you
watch if you engage the children and the
youth you will engage the adults you
will engage them especially if it has
some theological depth when I preached
the sermon that you first heard in
Chautauqua
I had a man who came up to me who had a
PhD in ecology he said that was the best
sermon on ecology I've ever heard huh
he said take what you need not what you
want okay now see that's the adult
processing going on so what you're doing
in a way of what I'm teaching you is a
parabolic way of preaching and there's
great precedent for that I'll let you
figure fill in who first did it so what
what these methods do is they help us
preach in a more parabolic way which
allows the engagement of the fullness of
the the human creature whatever their
age oh I wanted to point out a resource
here I've given you the classic work by
Howard Gardner intelligence reframed but
the book that really helps my students I
in Yolanda Smith actually we teach a
whole course on this semester long
course this is the book that the
students just love Thomas Armstrong it's
a paperback multiple intelligences in
the classroom Howard Gardner has read
the book and approves of as he's written
a preface to it but it's the practical
down-to-earth how do you actually do
this for teachers just substitute the
word teaching with preaching and you've
got it okay and he has diagrams and
shows you questions you can ask very
very usable stuff okay
can you all hear me all right
you're hearing me all right good okay
let me just oh the one other thing that
I wanted to point out about why I'm so
interested in this and I think this is
very important for our young people the
theory of multiple intelligences
provides us a method for claiming the
wholeness of our humanity as created by
God
one of the things I've been very
interested in is all our young people
thinking young people who read say
either read directly or in the newspaper
about the so-called new atheist Richard
Dawkins Sam Harris Christopher Hitchens
who are at about a kindergarten level
when it comes to theology
the the problem is they exercise I've
come up with this phrase this is my
phrase cognitive imperialism they raised
the rational linguistic and mathematical
function that's the judge of all truth
well it's not the judge of all shoe it's
tremendously helpful in dealing with
science and with certain analytical
problems but it doesn't begin to express
what I feel when I kiss my wife so I
mean there there are other ways of
knowing and that's another thing I like
about this is it's a challenge to that
over constricted / constipated way of
knowing okay gets things flowing again
because we have limited time and I do
want to be able to get in at least two
more sermons I'm going to do this one
briefly and then another one I want to
have times for questions and answers I
will not read this whole scripture it is
from John the text comes from the
lectionary and it's where Mary pours the
ointment on Jesus feet and the Gospel of
John but typical of the lectionary by
the way I tell this to all my preaching
students always be sure you read at
least one chapter in front and one
chapter afterwards always so you get the
context and if you do that in this case
at the end of 11 you discover that Jesus
had stopped going around in public
because the authorities were out to
arrest him so that is the back that sets
the stage for the party that happens and
here's the sermon on the party a just a
brief excerpt from it I apologize to
some of my students who in class they've
heard this sermon before so you'll just
have to listen again it's good enough
unforgettable it was an unforgettable
party how could it be anything else the
guest of honor was on the FBI most
wanted list the authorities were out to
arrest Jesus and here was a party to be
held in his honor I can't imagine what
it was like just before he arrives and
people are there you know having a drink
and a snack
you know how when there is something
extremely anxiety provoking in a room
it's the elephant in the room but nobody
talks about it
instead I can imagine conversations like
this
how are your tomatoes doing oh not so
well this year we had too much rain you
know that's right we had lots of Sun
last year they got much redder you know
that kind of little chitchat probably
going finally Jesus arrives I imagine
that it kind of became quiet that
awkward quiet like oh he's here I mean
they're glad he's here but there's the
fear that's in everybody's heart what
happens if the authorities come and they
find him here and they find me here will
they take me off with him
well I be an accessory to the crime but
that's not what really made it
unforgettable what made it really
unforgettable is when Mary came in sat
down at his feet and poured a pound a
pound of the most expensive perfume in
the world on his feet have you ever
bought perfume for yourself or someone
else I did once for my wife it was
Christmas I'd seen this ad about
fragrances of the world I thought that'd
be a nice gift so I went to this
department store I looked at the prices
and I figured if I ate peanut butter
sandwiches January through March
I would be able to afford it so they had
these little atomizers out you know what
I'm talking about it's a little glass
bottle and it's got a rubber squeezy
here and a nozzle now have this woman
who's standing there kind of like this
behind the counter and I come up and she
sees I'm gonna try one out you know see
which fragrance I like one squeeze
please this stuff is expensive yeah I
don't want me going okay so I pick up
another one I took another one I'll take
this one now let's say that there was an
ounce and I think that's what it was an
ounce in that bottle and let's say there
were a thousand squeezes just for the
sake of argument that would you know my
wife could she used behind both the
years in here you know you know behind
both savers would be five five hundred
days of nice fragrance but the text
tells us that Mary poured a pound of
this on Jesus if she had sprayed it she
would have been there all night she took
no wonder we're told that the whole
house was filled with the fragrance the
whole house I bet it was so rich that
they opened the windows and I bet if
somebody walked by in a tweed coat their
coach started smelling of it and if they
got on a boat the next day to go to Rome
the whole known world would smell the
fragrance of Mary's gratitude if you and
I lived a life filled with that much
gratitude toward Jesus Christ our whole
lives would be unforgettable now take a
minute and take the empty sheet the
you'll find that empty sheet and just go
through and just write a word or so that
shows you when I use that particular one
bum bum bum bum bum we're back I'm going
to do one last short sermon with you in
this sermon you have a part to play
that's another thing that I've
discovered and a nice thing if you don't
go the Mickey Mouse ear if you have
everybody integrated in I find that if I
ask a congregation to participate
especially there's something that the
children know the children will get
started and the adults will join in in
ways they overcome some of their
reservation it's another example of
where the little child shall lead them
okay so there is a part for you it comes
very near the end of this sermon and the
character in the sermon will cue you in
like this so when you see that you're to
join in the song believe me you know the
song I'm not even worried about that
okay so sing sing your hearts out there
at the ends alright now this is I often
think at Christmastime the church is
filled often children and families are
there here's a time even if your usual
pattern is the more Mickey Mouse ear
thing you know this is often a time the
year where I find in many churches
across many traditions whole families
are there so this form of preaching I've
find becomes very engaging for everyone
so this is a Christmas season sermon I
want you to imagine that you have gone
to the cinema you're going to see one of
your favorite films you're in the
theater and they've just finished all
the previews and in that little short
they run on the popcorn and please don't
talk be friendly to your neighbor and
put the trash in the ashcan all that
kind of stuff and then the theater goes
completely dark and then the war up on
the screen comes the first scene and as
they do I've noticed in many movies over
the last few years they don't have the
credits right away instead they have a
dramatic scene and this scene is
Broadway in New York City you recognize
it right away you see all the marquees
and it's clearly in the summer people
are in tank tops and shorts and there
are massive numbers of people on the
sidewalk and they're police on horses
trying to keep primeval chaos at bay and
I mean it's it's that usual busy scene
and taxis are honking at each other and
then there's the the camera pans down
the street and you see this
extraordinarily new modern building it
it's got to be a theater but it almost
looks like a spaceship and the camera
focuses in on it and on one side of the
marquee it says the new Millennial
theater opening in December and then on
each other side of the marquee it says
the greatest Christmas pageant in
history coming in December and then
there's a pistach of tunes with the
Boston Pops playing Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer and hark the herald
angels sing you know one after another
and while that's happening the credits
roll by you can just put in your
favorite actresses or actors I'm sure to
get Meryl Streep in there
at any rate as this as the credits
finish you get a real close-up of this
theater and you're looking down from the
air and you can see that the roof is
cantilevered so that it could be opened
and they could do a play where you could
look up and see the heavens and then the
camera swoops down and there is an aisle
along the side a little alley along the
side of this theater and it's jammed
with people and the camera goes over
their heads and it says at Actors Equity
tryouts for the greatest Christmas
pageant in history all of a sudden
there's a fade-out and you're inside
this new theater and there's a director
you've seen this scene he's at a table
reading the the script for the play in
the days of Caesar Augustus there went
out a decree that all the world should
be taxed and there's another guy who's
kind of his Lackey who's running around
getting things ready finally says boss
they're here the actors the actresses
for the tryouts Letterman so he lets
them in they all run in and they take
seats in the theater and the director
says number one so this lovely young
woman gets up who looks kind of like a
French milkmaid and he says to her who
are you she says I'm Jeannette Isabella
you know bring a torch the net is up
there la bring a torch to the stable run
and the director goes in the days of
Caesar Augustus they went home dude
there's no Jeanette Isabella and this
but you know you would be lovely as an
angel why don't you go sit down over
there so the next thing they say um
number two well number two turns out to
be three act actors three
african-americans who come out and they
have broken shackles
and the director says who are you and
they say we're the Forgotten ones of
history
he says they forgot in the days of
Caesar Augustus sir whether there are no
forgotten ones a history in this they
said oh yes there are we're in that
story and we understood that story so
profoundly that we gathered together a
song about it go tell it on the mountain
over the hill and everywhere go tell it
on the mouth tinda Jesus Christ is born
and the director against his best
judgment finds himself tapping his foot
is it this is a terrific song he says
maybe we'll make it a musical why didn't
you go over there
so the next thing that happens is a guy
comes out in a big frocking 18th century
coat and he has a big wig on him and the
director says who are you
and he says some oh I'm the orde
Friedrich Handel in the days of Caesar
Augustus er without decree and all the
world that there's no handle in here and
handle says I wrote a great song about
this for unto us a son is given a child
is born and the government shall be and
the tractors oh my god he says we could
put back together with go tell it on the
mountain and we'd have a terrific show
go sit down over there so the next thing
that happens is to 19th century German
men come now who are you oh we're Yosef
more in France Gruber and if you don't
put our song in your show you won't sell
a single ticket oh holy in the days of
Caesar Augustus er when I was decreed it
there's no Joseph nor
Franz Gruber in here can somebody can
somebody please tell me what's going on
here so a woman with a sweatshirt on
that says youth ministry now gets up on
stage and says I can tell you because I
go to great youth ministry events and we
learn good theology there and she says
he says well how are you gonna explain
this and she says well actually with
another song she says I want you to open
that roof that cantilever group so the
Lackey goes and he pushes the buttons
and it opens and everybody looks up and
behold they see the angels in the
Archangels and the whole company of
heaven and the woman turns to all the
actors in the theatre and looks up at
the angels and archangels and goes joy
to the world the Lord is come
see she says to the director now do you
get it let every heart prepare him room
and just as she says that there is a big
sound at the door and the Lackey runs
and he looks out the door and he sees
millions upon millions of people from
every tribe and nation trying to get
into the theater and he goes to the
director and explains boss and he tells
it what he saw and the director turns to
the woman as though it's her fault and
says look lady if we let everybody into
this story who wants apart it's going to
go from everlasting to everlasting to
which the whole company of heaven and
everybody present said eh men now we
have ten minutes for questions
when you would do a sermon like this
where you would not have the children
with their families might be happen to
come closer so they get a better look
young people would you always leave them
where they are uh in this particular
case because it's Christmas I would
probably leave them there because it
there is a big family element in it but
there are times when it's helpful for
children just because they're smaller in
stature
although I because so many churches have
had me come out to do things with every
generation present and I've said to them
if you feel comfortable with it the
children can stand on the Pew and that's
been a very nice solution they've been
able to see another thing I just don't
have enough time to do all the things I
do but for example one place while I did
was I came on a Saturday I mean you
don't have to be a visiting priest or a
preacher to do this and I had the
children doing Bible studies of the same
passages that I was doing adult Bible
studies with the adults and then the
children drew pictures of them and this
was all the way from a preschool up
until about sixth grade then I had
somebody I got all this lined up ahead
of time made a PowerPoint of all of
those pictures I didn't have my sermon
until after I saw all the pictures and
then every I had asked for each child to
interpret the picture and I did I can
remember it was called travel tips for
the journey of faith that was I figured
out that I could do something with that
okay and I'll tell you it was absolutely
fabulous for example just to give you an
idea of how you can do this kind of
stuff one one kid had this his
watercolors just ran together in a blur
oh it was the temptation of Jesus story
and this was his interpretation looked
like a modern abstract painting so he
said this is the temptation of Jesus
it's not clear
and so I preached on you know sometimes
it's not clear about temptations it's
not crystal clear whether it's good or
evil it's like this picture and then we
had these projected on the screen the
next one was also on the temptation of
Jesus and it was Jesus and the devil
hiding behind a rock and the kid had
written the word know across the entire
thing and I said sometimes it is clear
and sometimes you have to shout no look
at what the kids are giving me the the
church loved it so much the creative
church they then made a calendar with my
sermon and the kids comments which they
sold at the annual church fair with
featuring these pictures so they kept it
I mean these are the things that can
begin to happen once if you start using
this stuff I'm giving you but it works
and you you it's just astounding what
you would be able to do astounding the
thing that just breaks my heart about
the church is it were you bored during
these sermons now you weren't bored why
are we having boring sermons when God
loves us infinitely how can you be
boring about that I mean I I don't I
don't understand that but but the way to
get over the boredom is to use the sum
total of the human creature you will
notice today now I've told you about my
use of PowerPoint I didn't use one
electronic device and the one electronic
device a you had can work
you were not dependent on electronics
10-gauge you were dependent am i using
the sum total of who God has made me so
I could engage the sum total of who you
are that is the secret for yes I do and
one of the things that I do for example
when I've gone out to these churches and
I'm going to do some of these things is
I will either teach them the theory and
why it's important and you'll notice I
gave you a theological reason why it's
important to love the Lord your God with
all your heart and soul and mind and
strength it's not condescending the
condescension that the judgment that
it's condescending comes from cognitive
imperialism as though this is the only
way to see and that's something that
leaves out how are we going to feed the
baby Jesus who's going to feed the baby
Jesus no he's really dead mommy those
are not condescending we need to hear
those things and that is a growing up
and a maturing on the part of people who
think it's condescending that they have
some growing up to do now you've got to
help them with it but you'll notice I
even built it into the sermon the first
sermon that I did remember I built in
the mom precisely because I know some
people might think oh is this okay so
you may recall I used some pretty big
authority things issues there I used
quoting Isaiah I related it to Jesus and
unless you become as a child once I
start doing that I think that the
feeling of condescension goes down so
you are right to be concerned about it
you do have to have a strategy for
speaking to it but you can't let it
paralyze you yeah
you didn't just serving addicts you
engaged us - exactly so whether whether
you verbalize that although that's what
I'm trying to do the theories that I'm
giving you allow it to be with and not
at okay that's that's what these
theories do I think but that's great you
have three you know I love it see I gave
you two but you have three you're like
Jesus multiplying the one that's great
no the third one was the multiple
intelligences okay right yeah no but I
can see how you would have seen the
maturing one as a third one makes good
sense to me yeah and this causes certain
problems too gives people all the time
on copies of my sermons but what I say
is a sermon is not what's on a piece of
paper if you were to go out here and had
a piece of paper with what I've just
done with you for the last hour and hand
it to somebody that wouldn't be what you
experienced right okay you you can't
give somebody on a piece of paper
everybody's singing joy to the world at
the end and with the meaning that that
set up yeah Danny
yeah okay what did you all hear that
what's the creative process one of the
chief ones that I do that I've told you
about is I actually I do this less
self-consciously now but I have at
certain points done it very
self-consciously taken the multiple
intelligences and actually used it to
read the biblical text and it's revealed
to me things I didn't see in the text
before or the other thing that I've done
I've done it less now that I'm here but
I used to be able to do it even in in
Denver because I was a member of the
church I've actually talked with a child
about here's this passage what do you
think of beings and that children often
give you the best stuff I mean they it's
just priceless stuff and because they
are so unguarded they're so unguarded
the other thing I like about the child's
thing and you can really see it in the
sermon I did on the feeding the 5,000 I
think of all of the damn debates I've
heard about did it literally happen what
was it that just everybody shared was it
you know it goes on and on you're never
gonna solve those debates my god okay
some people are gonna believe it
literally happened some people think
it's a metaphor somebody thinks it's
everybody shared if you step into that
pool you will sink okay but the child
keeps you from doing it he all he does
is he stays simply at the literal
magical level mom I gave my lunch away
then I ate my lunch then I had more than
I had before okay and then that
wonderful thing about I figured out you
can feed more people than you think you
can okay first you give it to Jesus let
him pray and then there's enough for
everyone now notice you can take it if
you're a literalist it's fine if you're
a metaphorical thinker it's fine okay
I'm I don't want the church wasting its
time on those theological debates when
they ought to be feeding the world okay
and that's what the child helps me do
okay we have at least time for one more
I think I I can't say I always used it
but I've been using it for so long I
can't remember when it started I'm 68
now so you know it's a long time that
we've I've been preaching since I was 25
okay okay first of all I generally
speaking do these things in ways where
children don't just get to respond there
because I have had the smart-aleck kid
who deliberately says something that is
smart and that's not necessarily helpful
what what I'm after is the serious
things children say like who's feeding
baby Jesus no he's really dead but one
of the things I have done when I have
had a spontaneous remark and it's been
left is I've built it into the sermon
I've taken it and made it a serious part
of the sermon so that the child sees
that I took it seriously okay
what kind of seeds was that plant in a
title that they in terms of the person
of growing I think what happens in I'll
take the second example no he's really
dead
I then preached on that as the sermon at
Good Friday and the little girl and her
mother was there and the mother came up
and I think was speaking for the child
when she said thank you for taking my
daughter so seriously so for a you see
what's happened the child knows I was
listened to the child who knows I was
listened to is the child who's going to
be in church when they grow up the child
who's ignored has no reason to come and
our time is up
thank you
I caught on to what was going on here
everybody figured out a kippah has new
questions we need to get the whole
homiletic scores without tuition we're
on our way you'll just have to sign up
for the course that was
you know you've seated this pod of this
creativity in the day that launched a
thousand your friends I just can't do it
what's going on Facebook for all we have
experienced in this community together
for this yearly thing for the creativity
and passion of those scholars and
pastors who joined us to share their
wisdom and experience inspiration with
us we think the food that's been laid
out before us and that we bless those
dance floor the passion that's been
received and experience what the folks
who come out on a beautiful day to learn
how to better pasture to our
congregations with our children we thank
you and asking to bless these efforts in
Jesus name Amen
thank you all see you next year